TREY: I'VE OFTEN WONDERED IF WE
SHOULD TALK AND LISTEN MORE WITH
ONE ANOTHER, NOT ARGUE, AND
YELL, BUT TALK, AND LISTEN, EVEN
IF WE DISAGREE.
JESSE WATTERS GOT HIS START IN N
TELEVISION.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
STATE OF THE NATION RIGHT NOW.
>> I'MISSED OFF
RIGHT NOW AS A COUNTRY.
REPORTER: HOW DO YOU THINK THAT
COUNTRY IS DOING.
>> LONGER THAN A RED CARPET.
REPORTER: WOULD YOU VOTE FOR
HIM.
>> NO.
REPORTER: WHY NOT.
>> I AM A REPUBLICAN.
REPORTER: HE IS A REPUBLICAN.
>> OH,.
REPORTER: WHAT YEAR DID WE SIGN
THE DECLARATION --
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT STUFF.
REPORTER: WHY DID YOU BOYCOTT
INAUGURATION, YOU SAID FOX NEWS
CHOKES US AND LIES TO US, WHO IS
US, WHAT ARE THE LIES?
TREY: JOINING ME NOW A FORMER
PRODUCTION ASSISTANCE AT FOX
NEWS, NOW HOST OF -- WATTERS
WORLD.
>> I AM GREAT, AFTER WATCHING
ALL MY OLD EXPLOITS, I FORGOT
HOW INTERESTING I USED TO BE.
>> ARE STILL INTERESTING.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN CONDUCTING
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
>> I LEARNED THAT I WAS IN THE
BUBBLE.
I LEARNED THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR POLITICIANS, THEY ARE LIVING
THEIR LIVES.
THEY ARE TAKING THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL, MAKING IT TO CLASS ON
TIME, THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT A FEW
THINGS, THE COST OF LIVING AND
TRAFFIC AND BASIC THINGS LIKE
GOING OUT TO DINNER.
DATING, AND PERHAPS SCHOOL.
OR WORK.
EVERYTHING EL, YOU HEAR ABOUT,
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
YOU KNOW.
THOSE THINGS, PEOPLE'S EYES
GLAZE OVER, THEY DON'T CARE,
THEY DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS TO A LARGE ETENT.
THEY JUST WANT THEIR LIVES TO BE
EASIER AND CHEAPER.
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH IT.
TREY: THAT IS A GOOD LESSON TO
LEARN FOR FOLKS IN DC AND NEW
YORK.
LET ME ASK YOU, IT STRIKES HE AS
REQUIRING A LOT OF SELF
CONFIDENCE TO WRITE A BOOK ON
SAVING THE WORLD.
AND REQUIRES A LOT OF HUMIDITY
TO PUT WHAT YOU PUT ON THE BACK
OF THE BOOK, WHY DID YOU WRITE A
BOOK ABOUT SAVING THE WORLD?
AND WE'LL GET TO THE BACK, I
FIND AMAZING WHAT YOU PUT THERE.
>> I WROTE IT FOR THE MONEY, MOI
NEEDED THE MONEY, I STILL DON'T
THINK I WAS PAID ENOUGH.
I HAD FELT LIKE I HAD GOTTEN TO
A PLACE IN MY LIFE, I HAD THE
TIME TO DO IT, I WANTED TO
REFLECT ON 20 YEARS ALMOST ON
FOX, TELL THE TRUTH WHAT I HAVE
LEARNED ABOUT MYSELF AND ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THE NEXT QUESTION?
TREY: THE STORIES IN THE BOOK
ARE VERY FUNNY.
YOU INSTEAD OF PUTTING
ENDORSEMENTS ON THE BACK, PUT A
SERIES OF INSULTS, INCLUDING ONE
PERSON I THINK THAT SAID YOU
WERE SHOCKINGLY IGNORANT.
THAT COULD BE A COMPLIMENT IN A
WAY, SHE WAS SURPRISED YOU WERE
IGNORANT, YOU PUT -- INSULTS ON
THE BACK.
>> I DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO GO
ON MY KNEES TO HANNITY ASKING
FOR A BLURB .
SOLEDAD O'BRIEN BELIEVES THAT I
AM SHOCKINGLY IGNORANT.
BROUGHT ME DOWN TO EARTH, I NEED
THAT.
TREY: A COMPLIMENT SHE WAS
SHOCKED.
THAT IS HOW I LOOK AT IT.
NOT LIKE YOU ARE BORINGLY
IGNORANT, YOU ARE SHOCKINGLY.
>> THE MOST COMPELLING PART OF
YOUR STORY TO ME IS YOU STARTED
ABOUT AS LOW AS YOU COULD START
ON FOX NEWS, NOW YOU ARE THE
HOST AND CO-HOST OF FABULOUSLY
POPULAR SHOWS, YOU GET TO SIT
NEXT TO DANA PERINO, HOW IT THAT
HAPPEN.
>> I THINK IT WAS A LOT OF LUCK.
I WAS IN THE RIGHT PLACE AT
RIGHT TIME.
AND I WAS TOLD TO DO THINGS.
TREY GOWDY, OBEDIENCE WAS
IMPORTANT.
I DID IT RIGHT AWAY, I WAS FIRST
DO IT I DID IT AS HARD AS I
COULD.
I DID THAT FOR ABOUT 15 YEARS.
NOW, I GET TO SIT NEXT TO DANA
PERINO, IN MY BOOK, I MADE IT.
I THINK THAT REST OF THE COUNTRY
WOULD AGREE.
TREY: IN ALL OUR BOOKS YOU MADE
IT.
YOUR BOOK MADE MY LAUGH.
INSIDE, AND THE BACK.
THIS MIXTURE OF SELF AWARENESS
AND HUME MILL TIE, WE COULD --
HUMILITY, WE COULD USE MORE.
CONGRATULATION TO HAVING A
NUMBER ONE "NEW YORK TIMES" BEST
SELLING BOOK AND ALL YOU HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED IN WELL.
>> THANK YOU, TREY, AND THE
PODCAST, ONE OF MAY GREATEST,
TREY GOWDY GRAPHICS PACKAGE IS
BOATER THAN "WATTER'S WORLD"?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
TREY: I THINK THEY FELL LIKE I
NEEDED IT MORE, THAT IS WHY.
THEY HAVE TO DRESS ME UP.
>> STOP, THANK YOU, TREY, YOU
ARE THE BEST.
TREY: TUR